[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and we're
back with another episode of this demo
rpg
and i have a new camera angle so enjoy
seeing my long nose and we're going to
be working on the inventory
so mainly what we're going to be doing
here is adding a backpack to the player
character so they have a place to store
their items because that's sort of
required and
i thought a lot about this i thought
about kind of making this global and
letting whoever's programming the game
instantiate them and we might actually
end up doing that
but for now what we're going to do is
just put a backpack on the player
character because your character's got
to be able to carry stuff i think that
makes sense and this also allows for it
to be a bit extensible
in the way that uh like monsters and
stuff are going to have backpacks too
so that uh later in theory when you
loot them
you'll be able to dig through the
backpack so all right well we're first
of all just going to see go to our
player character here and the main thing
we want to do is just add a vector of
items to the player character delegate
this player character delegate may be a
just character delegate later so it
could potentially be used for any
entity
in the world any living entity
so that's why we're going to extend it
onto this and we're just going to put it
here as a vector of
item
star now it's important that these are
item star because they're item pointers
if you make them actual items you might
end up accidentally copying
the items a lot and we don't really want
that to happen with unique stuff because
it'll call destructors and it'll
reconstruct and it'll potentially make
new unique ids when we don't want it to
but if it's just a
bunch of pointers in this vector
then the data is not really going to
change we might destroy and copy
pointers and some but that's kind of
insignificant compared to the problems
that we could have otherwise all right
and we're just going to call this
backpack for now so there we go we have
a vector of items our vector of item
pointers rather i hope that makes sense
as we're trying to get into that
we're going to go down to where the
player character is now which is way
down below here player character there
it is
so what we can do
this this file is really big
and that's fine i plan on cleaning it up
later later these main classes i'm just
kind of going off on a side tangent here
just fyi this whole set of stuff after
the player this this whole set of stuff
here is somewhat you know it's specific
to these classes and it's going to have
the level of trees and all that so we
might move this somewhere else later and
just to keep everything else cleaner but
for now we're not going to worry about
it too much but i am going to collapse
them for this episode so that when we're
scrolling it's easier to tell what
things are
of course we have these macros i'm going
to put these macros
somewhere else like at the very top here
just moving that around a little bit to
make it look a little cleaner and so
that we can collapse it nicely and work
with it now this depends on your id
maybe you don't collapse maybe you do
sometimes it's nice to be able to do but
we're going to be
just fixing this up a little bit
and working with the backpack we're
going to need a few things first of all
we're going to need a weight or we're
going to need to change these functions
that equip and use items to actually
think about
inventory system so i'm just kind of
going through and collapsing things so
you can see everything that we have here
lots of getters oh i think it looks
clean like this when you just have all
your getters in one big chunk
and you can expand them out if you need
to work with them but that's your call
some ids have a hot key to uncollapse
and collapse on collapse you can also
navigate up here so however you want to
do it is fine
it's uh not not too big of a deal i
guess is the point but i just want to
explain how i'm doing it because
otherwise people might get a little
confused
we might fix a few other things while
we're at it like this get buff list that
just calls get buff list and some of
these that just call the same thing we
might refactor those but for now we're
just going to leave it but you know i've
noticed and kind of tweaked a lot of
things in the meantime while figuring
out the inventory and that tends to
happen so we're going to make a new
function here let's see in the modifiers
so we've got this modifier set i'm just
kind of you know keeping these nice
getters here all the modifiers here
and
we'll get rid of these comments now
because we're not going to eat them so
what we're going to add here is a
function that is just called move to
inventory
and we'll we'll do a boolean again to
see if it's succeeded or not move to or
move to backpack or other
and this is going to of course take the
item to move
a pointer to it item to move
and let's go ahead and work this
function out
so first of all we want to do the
standard checks we were doing before
just make sure there's make sure the
pointer is not null if it is we just
returned so we'll just copy that down
not only the item needs to be not null
but the data it has also has to be not
null so we're probably there might be a
way to clean up those checks to not do
them all the time every time we call
these but we'll think about that a
little later if we end up doing some
refactoring the main thing we need to do
is just call
backpack the pc classes backpack and
just push this item in it so
backpack.pushback
item
to move now if we think about this
what is going to happen here
is it's just going to move this pointer
or it's going to push back the pointer
which depending on your version of c
plus plus and it might do different
things it might it might copy it
or it might or might copy the pointer
which is okay we just need to think
about memory management there because if
we move something to the backpack
we don't necessarily want anything else
to manage it from there it should now be
managed specifically by the backpack and
that's something we just need to
consider is who controls this memory
because if we're passing around pointers
to it if one person modifies it the
actual data it's pointing to it's going
to essentially modify everywhere and
that can be intended or not intended so
just something to keep in mind as we go
here
so if we get to this state we just
return true and we're just going to keep
it that simple for now we literally just
pass it in there it puts it in the
backpack
now there's only very few ways we can
mess with the backpack right now
right now it's literally just this
function
but
i think what we actually want to do is
make this function private because we
don't want anyone to call it yet
so let's just go down here and
just put private right here
these deleted constructors it really
doesn't matter if they're public or
private we can leave them private so
it's fine but we want this to be private
because we don't want anyone to call
this just yet it's going to be used
internally through this equip or use
function no let's make it public okay
because
because i guess you know we want to be
able to loot stuff and move it but
ideally this might actually happen
through an item manager so that we can
be more careful with that pointer it's
kind of what i was thinking but for now
we will leave it public but it might
change in a later episode
okay so now let's refactor equip and
let's refactor this use to more properly
use
or to move stuff so what's going to
happen now with these move or this equip
is we used to just delete what was in
the old slot like if you equipped if you
equipped an item
like say if you equipped a helmet and
then you equipped another helmet it
would just delete the old one and equip
the new one now we want to take that old
one and put it into the inventory so
this delete right where we have this to
do here
is just gonna we're just gonna call move
to backpack oops
and then on that item so
this is a little tricky here
we have we have to think about this
carefully
because the thing is this actual
equipped armor
it's not the item to equip it's the data
in the item to equip
right here we get item.data
but we have to move
the old item basically
so we need to a way to get that
and that's where things are gonna get a
little tricky and we might have to do
some refactoring okay i might have had a
bug in the way i kind of pre-set this
code so we're gonna fix it on the fly
here all right let's walk through this
all right so just to make sure we
understand it say we call equip the
first time it's going to be fine there's
going to be nothing equipped this is
going to equip it but what happens to
the item exactly and who's managing it
now does anyone else have access to the
pointer still well whoever called this
function still does
so that's not exactly what we intended
yeah this gets messy at this point
because the
item manager
doesn't really work with with this the
way it is we can create armor if we go
to our item manager we can create stuff
but this once it returns this pointer it
doesn't do anything else with it it's no
longer in control of it and we know that
if one of these items goes out of scope
it
will actually delete
the data
of this item delegate
and same with all these weapons if they
go out of scope
they're supposed to delete any pointers
they have these ones don't have any
pointers so they're handled but this
item star
does get deleted so we don't want to
delete it because then that's going to
mess up stuff
and if we're moving items around
we know that items right now have unique
slots are unique if we look at equipment
delegate here they have unique ids
so if we say
decide uh
we're not going to move it around we're
just going to like create a new one with
that data it would create a new unique
id and we don't want that to happen so
we need to think about that so the
reality is it would probably make a lot
more sense to have
this item manager
handle
more stuff that way we can carefully
keep track of these items just a little
bit better
so i think it makes sense
to take these equip and use item and
move back to backpack to just take these
completely out of here let's go ahead
and undo
this move the backpack i'm going to do a
just a hot copy and base here all right
so let's go ahead and just
take all this
and i'm going to do a cut
just ctrl x
and we're going to go over to the item
manager and we're going to paste them in
here
now we're going to have to fix these up
so let's start from the top first of all
these are all going to be static
so we can just put static in front of
all of them and they need to
know where the item is going so this
needs access to a character
that is
going to get the item equipped
so we need to pass in a character and
what what do we need here well let's
look at how we're instantiating our guy
we need a player character
all right so we need to pass in here
player character and we can we can do it
in multiple ways we could do it as a
reference or we could do it as a pointer
and really either or okay we just uh
let's just do it as a pointer for now
all right so we'll go player character
um we just need to give it a name here
we'll just call it uh
i'll just call it p character or p care
now you can't just do care
uh yeah p care is fine it sounds a
little weird
but we're gonna do that for all these
when you use an item
who would he gonna say who it's getting
used on and that's gonna go off of
their inventory
so there's more functionality we're
gonna need to to build up here basically
so if we're gonna have this move to item
move it to playercharacter's item we're
gonna have use and equip so this will
essentially allow us to use items from
anywhere
but
this brings up sort of another issue
well i guess it's not too big of an
issue because
well
we just need to make sure it doesn't get
duped anywhere or exist in two places or
something like that
or if it does it needs to be
specifically intended like
if it's on a hot bar or something and
the hot bar is supposed to share a slot
then they should both share the same
pointer
but if not then you know we don't we
don't necessarily want to do that so
since we're taking a pointer to the item
it's going to work off its data no
matter where
that item is it should be okay but we
might need to update that later too to
consider which backpack it's coming out
of but for now there's only going to be
one essentially so
it should be okay well i guess there's
kind of two if you think about it
there's the one the player character has
sure but then there's like the global
universe one which right now is actually
just our main because in our main we're
just creating items and this is
essentially our world space so items you
know
the memory we're managing uh in this
main is kind of a world space so
essentially we kind of have two
inventories one that's like you know
this is like god mode where we can do
whatever we want with items and then
we're gonna have the players backpack
that's gonna be more carefully managed
but we also need to consider
this stuff here too and what's going on
with it and where it's in and what these
pointers are doing because if we put one
of these items into a player character's
backpack we shouldn't mess with it
globally anymore or maybe if it's a
quest item maybe we should so just
things to think about this gets really
complicated when you try to wrap your
head around all the different scenarios
of what can happen and
it's not always super easy to develop
most people use
most people just
well not many people code this from
scratch what i'm trying to say most
people just grab a little add-on for
whatever and just use the add-on because
it's easier that way and it's probably
more optimized we're not really going
for optimization right now although it's
not going to be too bad using pointers
it's going to be pretty decently
optimized just by innate design
now with all that theory crafting out of
the way let's uh let's start with this
move to backpack method
so first things first item manager is
not going to have access to
private stuff in this pc class
because this is going to be like
p character
pc class and then backpack push back
it might be dot here
yeah top backpack there it is oh okay
that's right
but the thing is
um pc class is private so you may have
learned from a couple previous episodes
there's ways around this census is
private
it does make sense for the item manager
to be able to mess with the player
character so it's okay to make it a
friend brand
class item manager there we go now only
the functions in this item manager class
can touch this stuff so that is good
because that's what we intend and then
we can design our memory management of
this backpack stuff right in here as we
go and i'm probably going to change
these functions around as we go like
let's capitalize this stuff first of all
and we are just going to keep doing
compiler error development that's
basically what we've been doing most of
the time
so this should in theory work just fine
we got an item take the player character
move it to its backpack
and
now this doesn't consider whoever passed
in this item to move
it doesn't consider what they're doing
with this uh
pointer
they could they could still have control
of it we essentially both have control
over at this point which is sort of
dangerous
and it also doesn't consider if this
player character is null which it could
be so let's just check that
uh if
not
the character we'll just return false
and we might even be able to clean this
up a little bit by just doing something
like this
just or all of these
uh we probably want to do it in this
order
because if i remember correctly
these operate you have stuff in
parentheses it tends to operate from
right to left so first we want to check
that the item exists and then that the
data then that the character exists or
maybe we want to check the character
first before even
citing the item so in that case we
should put it on the right now this
doesn't matter a ton but
it just means we have to check less
things if the thing that gets checked
first might trigger the false on on this
or
because if it
has to go through the things that are
most likely not going to be null then
it's going to check more things and it
can affect the efficiency of your code
so something to keep in mind if your
checks are expensive which these are
rather cheap but if you're doing
something like a call in a function here
that returns a trigger false it's
important to put the one that's most
likely to fail on the right side i
believe it's the right side correct me
if i'm wrong all right so there we go
we've made that a lot less lines of code
basically and we still do what we intend
there
and returns true if it succeeds and and
let's go ahead and fix up these other
functions so equip now
now we need to think about this okay we
gotta we'll do the same check we'll just
do this check
and uh let's put this at the top looks
good it's now item to equip not item to
move
and we're still going to do the same
stuff here when we go to equip
let's check if it's armor if it is armor
then we go ahead and uh get that slot
and see if there's something currently
equipped in that slot
so we got to check that on the character
here like so
now that we're using this style function
and if so
we want to move the old one
the old item into the backpack however
this is
the get data part this equipped
currently equipped armor
so that's kind of the problem we
actually run into here so we can need to
think about that now there's a couple
different ways we could do this
we could make a
move constructor or we could make
let me think about this
or the other thing we could do is in our
character we could be
saving these references of all these
equipped things that's probably going to
make more sense in the long run
and it's just going to require a little
extra thought
because if we think about it we got
these are just equipment delegates
they're not items and
what they probably need to be
is
actual items because if we look at this
it would have to be an item delegate
and then instantiate it down through
equipment and then armor
to have all this item stuff
available
because right now
it doesn't have this item stuff
available
i think i'm saying that right
okay then we no longer want the player
manager to manage items it's going to be
done by the item manager specifically
okay we might accidentally introduce
some bugs here but i think what we need
to do here essentially and it is uh
turn these equipment delegates into
just plain old items
and this will make more sense shortly
because basically we need to store
this entire thing
otherwise
it's not going to go so well eventually
because what happens when we try to swap
is
you know we're looking at only this data
but we're not holding a reference to the
item to equip we're only holding the
data in the slot so we need to actually
know what item it is to swap basically i
hope that makes sense
but it's essentially going to be the
same uh for the most part and i'll
explain we'll walk through it so this is
all still the same
we still do want to know if this data is
armor or not because we don't want them
to equip a potion and these still should
fail so this will be the same
but
okay and this getting the slot will be
the same but let's look at the case
where we're equipping fresh stuff this
this one here is if the current slot is
filled
uh then we're we'll do a
move old item to backpack to do here
let's look at this case here where it's
it's a fresh slot and nothing's equipped
that's this else right here
we don't want to call this on armor we
want to call this on item to equip now
because this equipped armor slot is now
this item to equip this might not have
forward populated just yet
but that is what it is oh it's uh
because we gotta
reference it from the character so these
now all should have this going on all
right we'll get to the weapon in a
second it'll essentially be the same
just with weapon
all right so now
what this means is this equipped armor
slot is actually going to store the
reference to the item so we can move
that into the backpack
as as we want so we can literally just
call move to backpack
and we can call it on
the item well
we call it on the old slot which is this
slot here
and it's already a pointer and we need
the character
for that function to work with
so this function it'll just call this
one here and we'll move the stuff check
all the references
and just you know put it on its list
this backpack list
and then it's uh going to equip the new
one
so move old item to backpack and then
it's going to equip the new item item
and that should take care of it
and we're essentially going to do the
same thing down here with weapon
let's just clean up this code and make
it as concise as possible
and i don't think we really need
comments in this case we might put one
at the very top here like right here
whips a
weapon or armor and returns true
turns false all right that should sort
out the comment
and
yeah
it tells you what it does
if there was a previous slot and uh
that's a fine comment
so now we just gotta work up this
this weapon one
and we're just going to copy this code
here and paste it
because it is essentially the same we
just need to change all these
mentions of armor
to weapon
and all these mentions of equipped armor
to equipped weapon little copy paste
action and this will go quickly
oh we forgot to bring down what
oh i spelled this wrong
weapons is plural
so we don't say armors but we do say
weapons so i don't know little
those could be renamed but it's fine as
long as we get the point so that that
should work
and it should work fine because it's
literally only going to try with the
weapons and armor anything else you try
to equip is just going to return false
and that should be okay so equip should
be done
let's check out this use function
we're going to do the same initial base
case check here
except it's now item to use rather than
item to equip and we're going to do the
same kind of cast check to see if the
data is a potion or not and if it is a
potion we'll try to do some stuff
this apply buff is part of the pc
character
so we will do it like so the potion has
a buff
we will apply it
and same logic here but we just want to
make sure we
are calling this on the character don't
use the potion after full health and it
doesn't have a buff but then the potion
doesn't have a buff do a little hp
increase
and reduce the potion quantity
and now here's where it gets a little
different if the potion quantity is zero
it just currently calls delete potion
that's going to leave some dangling
pointers
unless we make sure it cleans up any
references any any pointers pointing to
that data because while this will delete
the data the pointer is still going to
exist and we're going to get an error
and in our code runtime probably so
that's not good so what do we want to do
here let's think about this for a second
well
we probably want a little function
that anytime a potion is reduced to zero
yeah sure we set it to null we deleted
and set it to null but also we need to
clean up the user's backpack or
inventory of potions
so that's just something we need to
think about
now we could call this anytime we call
any function that works with the
backpack but really we only need to call
it
when something is being deleted and i
think the way we're going to do this is
we're going to mark things for deletion
that way on the next game update the
next time it could process things it
will
it will delete anything it's marked for
deletion so rather than just do it
instantly
we'll mark it
so we're going to go potion which is an
item
and just mark for deletion we'll make a
function for this
mark or deletion
now our potion
is an item
or an item delegate so we can put this
all the way at the top
because in theory any item could be
deleted and let's just put it in
protected here or well let's uh let's
make a function
void mark or deletion but you can just
call
and let's make a protected variable
that's a bool
well i'll make it underscore or well no
underscore just marked for
deletion we'll start it out as false
and we just want to change that to true
marked for deletion
equals true
so now we can call this function and
it'll mark for deletion but what's the
actual delete gun gonna do
well it's basically gonna clean up an
item entirely if it's marked for
deletion this will also allow you to
delete junk out of your inventory so we
can use this later if we want a little
thing that says all right i picked up
all this scrap that i can't even hardly
sell or something like that in our game
and you just want to get rid of it you
should be able to just delete it or at
least drop it
for now we're just going to do delete
but later we might change that to
maybe we'll give an option for destroy
or drop
it just depends on the game
some games say you can only drop and
then it disappears if it sits in the
world for too long so we just need to
make a decision and we're gonna just
decide to delete things only just for
ease of use
so in this case what we want to do
is we want to have a way to go through
these items and clean them up basically
it might even make sense to put that
function here
but since it has well yeah let's do it
actually in here
so because if it's in the delegate then
it's like this actual data here it's
going to exist in this private data we
don't necessarily want that we want it
to handle somewhere else so we'll do the
mark for deletion in the actual item
that way it doesn't
that way it can be like more public and
we still have this friend class item
manager
so only the item manager could access
this
boolean of whether it's marked for
deletion or not
now we need to think about is that
something we intend because ultimately
i think no i think we're going to make
that public for now
if it's public we don't even really need
this function
uh you know let's do this a slightly
different way
okay so let's leave this boolean in
private and only the item manager can
set it that way only the item manager
can change this marked for deletion and
then let's
let's just do a get
that way anyone can check if it's marked
for deletion
get
marks or deletion sure i'm doing this
camel case for public
this underscored version for private
kind of mixing it up a little bit but i
tend to do something like that usually
just to be able to tell
rather than putting a p or
you know something like that
this way not just any random person can
mark stuff for deletion it has to be
done through the item manager and we can
do it right here
marked
so this
we also need to think about
just in the same way we were we had to
refactor this to to equip the actual
item and not just
the data we also need to do the same
thing here this potion here is just the
data we need to actually make this item
to use
and also if we end up marking something
we could just go ahead well until we
have a core game loop that might check
this every so often we probably want to
just do it anytime we mark something new
for deletion is just call
clean up
inventory and
then don't worry
or clean up backpack rather
and this is a function that can exist on
the character so we can just call it on
this character since we have a reference
to it here this is definitely something
that's going to be
refactored later i think but let's go
ahead and go to the player character and
just make a cleanup
function somewhere
so the item manager has access to
private stuff let's let it let's give it
a function for cleanup backpack here
we could even put this in
the delegate where we have the actual
backpack
i guess it's debatable how you want to
do it
it would work fine either way
uh let's make a hot change let's take
this backpack
out of the player character delegate and
just put it in the character class
as a private vector of items it's going
to really work the same way
either way
essentially all we want to do with this
cleanup backpack function is just go
through and delete any
data and remove it from the backpack and
we already know that these items
they've got a destructor that's going to
destroy their data so as long as we
destroy this item or call delete on it
or free however you want to do it
it's it's going to delete the all the
internal stuff
so we just need to call that and there's
an algorithm we're going to use so we
could write this manually
but since we're already using vector
let's go ahead and use algorithm because
you can imagine how we'd have to do it
we'd basically have to go through the
vector
delete the data and then remove it but
there's some functionality to do this we
just need to get the iterator of any of
them that are marked for deletion
and we can do that i'll walk through all
this
we just need to get the iterator right
so we're going to make an auto we'll
call this to remove
and we're going to call it function
standard remove if
that exists in that algorithm header
so what we need here is a a iterator
where it begins and where it ends and we
just want that vector so we just go
backpack dot begin
that's the beginning of the vector and
all we want to search all the way
through backpack backpack.n
and then we want
the case
here at the end and we're going to use
something that you may not have seen yet
we're going to use a lambda now all the
lambda really is is an info in place
function and we just want this function
to return true or false we want it to
return true
the item is marked for deletion and we
wanted to return false otherwise that
way we can get all the stuff to remove
and uh the way you make lambdas is with
square brackets parentheses and then the
squiggly brackets
and there's a lambda
so i'm going to just break this the end
of this remove if down here so we can
see what we're working with so this here
is a function and we need to make sure
it returns so you can this is optional
if you just have return
through here for example it'll return
true all the time
uh okay we need
that there to end the remove if so
that's returning true all the time oh my
goodness i've made this small the whole
time here we go let's make it bigger now
but we don't want it to return true all
the time you can also make this lambda
let's break this lambda to a new line
but just keep in mind it's the last part
of this to remove
so you can specify right here that
returns a boolean like so after these
parentheses i just
but also it's it's implied that what it
returns so you don't necessarily have to
have this here all right but we actually
just want to return well we need to
operate on something so it needs to take
something in this case we're taking in
const
item you know whatever this backpack is
basically it's an item star so that's
what we're taking into this lambda and
we'll just call it i
i for item sure
and we want to return
i
marked for deletion
or is marked
what do we name this get get marked for
deletion
so this will return true if it is now
this is complaining about something
uh
what's this we're complaining about
oh it's const
okay gotcha we actually want this to be
const as well constable
there now it's going to be happy just
wants everything to match up
i think oh oops
one other thing we want to do here now
this const is kind of optional here it's
probably going to be returning a copy
anyway but we want this function to be
const which basically just says this
function does not change anything in
this item class uh and that has to be
like that oops i keep going to the wrong
one
because
and this here is const so it just wants
it to match up to say hey the item's
const the function you're calling should
be const too just to make sure you're
actually not changing anything so
kind of a nice little warning there
and this const is a little more optional
at this point i think it'll be fine
either way
all right so that'll get
an iterator of the stuff to remove
uh and then we just want to call
erase on this backpack basically
erase which is another function in
algorithm or actually it's in vector
and we need to call it on the iterator
that we want to erase there we go
so this remove if and erase they're kind
of black boxes but you can go look them
up you can google search them or if
you're in a
you know you can go to the header file
it's f12 or you can follow however you
do it on your ide but i just hit f12
and it goes straight to the function so
this is the actual function that it's
calling as you see it takes a forward
iterator
first and a last and then and then a
predicate which basically was a true or
false and it runs through and you can
walk through all this and see what it
does and you can do the same thing
for a race if you want to see what that
is
check that out
now you got to make sure it's sometimes
it'll the visual studio will go to the
function that's like somewhat the wrong
version but this seems to be correct so
he wants a concentrator where
so i guess if we're being very technical
we should probably make all these
iterators cons this auto might work for
that yeah this should be fine
if we put const here doesn't make any
difference no it doesn't seem to it
seems fine so that will
okay so basically all that's going to
end up doing is anytime we call cleanup
backpack something's marked for deletion
it's going to call a race on it and our
race should call delete
i believe now we probably want to test
this
just to make sure but if we look at from
this bracket
to this bracket
that's the entire function so we could
if we wanted to we could walk through
all this very carefully and just make
sure it's calling something it looks
like we do call destroy here
and i'm not entirely sure what all this
does but i think it'll work fine on a
pointer
we should probably do a little google
search and make sure okay so i typed
into google
just calling a race
on a vector of pointers does it call
delete properly c plus plus and it looks
like we got some answers here
and we probably want to
just review these and just make sure
we're doing things right make sure we're
not getting a memory leak
looks like they're doing it a little
differently here let's call let's search
a race now they don't even talk about a
race here we're specifically talking
about a race
now i kind of warned against some of
these but it sometimes it doesn't hurt
to read them because generally it's
decently vetted
okay looks like we could even put this
remove if inside the uh yeah just right
inside a race because a race has an
overload so let's actually do this okay
can you
think whole thing popping up there's
kind of annoying all right
but does this actually delete the
pointer
if they're unique pointers
it will sure but if they're not unique
pointers it probably isn't so we're
probably going to have a memory leak see
here we go standard remove well
you end up with a memory leak so we are
probably leaking memory here and the
easiest fix to this is probably to bank
those unique pointers but
what we actually want to do is delete
the pointer basically
as we go through all right and we can do
that
we can actually do that like right here
and in this here and
it's going to look a little odd
maybe there's more efficient
we can say if mark for deletion
so we're now getting logic inside our
lambda might look a little weird to some
you but
i'm kind of used to these at this point
get some practice with lambdas i have a
video on lambdas if you search my
channel just search like all about
lambdas i have a video that essentially
goes over everything about lambdas
that's probably a pretty good watch if
you're not used to them
and
yeah if it's marked for deletion we want
to call delete
on
that item let's make sure we do this
right
okay so this isn't exactly going to work
how we think but it looks like the
answer here is stable partition so
that's pretty interesting and with
stable partition
uh we need to reverse the predicate so
it's kind of the same thing except
stable partition here
and we don't we're not going to do this
delete yet now i should probably explain
a little bit more about what this remove
if and stable partition here in this
case
does
it does move around things in the
inventory some
because it uh it sorts things so that
everything that's being deleted is at
the end that's why you only need one
iterator because it's from that to the
end that it deletes so it puts all the
stuff to keep at the front and all the
stuff after
that or after
this iterator and to the end gets
removed
now you can read more about stable
partition i'm not going to explain it
totally but since we're doing these raw
pointers that's why we have to do it so
let's keep cleaning this up and then
we'll run a few tests and we'll probably
be about done here all right
now let's see here our predicate here is
going to be
uh the same thing except it's going to
be a not
yet marked for deletion
just because we're doing stable
partition we need to do it
backwards and then after calling that so
we get we get it sorted and and that
stuff and then we need to go and do a
for each i'm just going to do a little
copy paste here
and then fix it for our code
to remove
this is backpack.end
and then we need to call delete on it
like so
and that
should work because we'll be calling
delete on this item which is in turn
going to call delete on the data with
this destructor so that should clean up
everything properly and then we need to
do one more thing
so this essentially is
going to delete the all the data inside
of it and stuff but it's going to leave
this pointer dangling until we call the
final erase which i'll just copy over
here
uh
backpack.erase
from this to remove to the end of the
backpack
there we go so that's going to be our
proper cleanup
so
yeah that's all explained here i'll
leave a link to this down below but uh
if i got this slightly wrong you are
totally welcome
to uh correct it on github
another solution is to delete the
pointers and then set them in the
pointer and then uh do remove on all the
null pointer okay so yeah we could do
something like that too
but uh this is fine we get to practice
with stable partition
for each and erase and the next thing to
do is just test this and make sure it
actually does what we intend
so cleanup backpack is essentially going
to be
sort of a black box function because
it's going to be hidden away privately
in the end and if it's messed up we just
need to go correct it
but essentially once this works
correctly we probably never want to
touch it again and we just call it when
needed and that's it
so that's the way things are with black
box functions but they need well tested
and been well tested all right
so we're pretty much ready to start
testing out these items and see if we
what happens when we equip multiple helm
see if one goes the inventory and move
potions of the inventory that sort of
thing there's one thing i want to do
real quick and that's just go to these
core stats and just make a new
constructor
that is just a base case constructor
because right now we sure we have this
but we want to also just be able to
uh like in constructors if if it doesn't
have any stats or if they're all zero we
just want to be able to call this
that'll be kind of nice and we also want
one that just sets them all currently we
had overloaded some operators which is
fine but we need a few more constructors
just to help us out a little bit so
there's also another one that just takes
each stat type and sets it
and that's just going to help us going
forward a little bit so close that and
now we can go to our main
and start testing stuff out so let's do
this all right first of all let's
let's see sure we'll create our warrior
first thing that's fine and now we want
to do these core stats and all this
equip stuff a little differently
in fact we don't want to have these in
their own scope anymore because this is
kind of we're going to like have a
little global management for the moment
now essentially i will reiterate that
this is basically a big test
class
uh
and we want this to be armor
so yeah we can use some of these
constructors here
if we need to that we made
all right
uh zero
five three okay
so we can just do these in place for
some of these
going to be a it's going to save us a
little small place a little uh i don't
know what i'm trying to say a little
room i guess and we don't want to
necessarily equip it yet so let's just
delete all that code um
we're going to do another create armor
and this one's also going to have some
core stats you know let's make you know
we got full plate
let's
let's make leather armor and we'll just
try it we'll test this out with couple
pieces of armor so this is plain
leather apartment
and we'll lower the stats a little bit i
got two and a one and we need to make
sure it's the the right slot here both
chest
because this way if we equip one and
quit the other the one that
we originally equipped should go into
our inventory so let's just test that
out uh we'll make our sword here too
sure why not
sword has no stats at all
but it does have the damage that's kind
of a different case
now we haven't actually equipped
anything yet uh you know we're saying
all our character stuff here including
what's in their slots
i guess we'll leave all that code there
it's kind of you know we've seen it in
every episode it's kind of long
we've got those three items
let's try moving them to the inventory
all right let's just try equipping them
so we just go p1.equip
oh we have a get we can't call equip
anymore we actually need to use the item
manager like we changed it item manager
whip and we need to pass it
the player well the item then the player
so let's first equip this full plate
and then it needs the character
now obviously here the character is not
a pointer so
we can't just it wants a pointer so we
need to use a reference to give it a
pointer
and that's it if we made this a pointer
and instantiated as that we could just
pass it but
uh this this will be fine okay so that
should equip the full plate
and then we can equip the leather armor
and what should happen is
uh once it equips the other armor it
should put this full plate into our
inventory and we'll check that later
down the line and let's also just equip
this long sword just to make sure it
equipped properly with long sword to
player one
and we're looking pretty good here so we
had also
this use item that got changed too it's
now
item manager
use
and then we need the character to use it
on so we'll leave that in here just to
make sure it all works too
leave a few cl statements and also at
the very bottom here
we need to keep track of the inventory
so we create a healing potion and we use
a healing potion but we didn't actually
put it in the inventory so we need to
actually put this in the inventory let's
do that
and you could essentially do the same
thing with equipment on the fly let's
for example just make some other sword
like a short sword or no we'll make it
hand axe
we'll call it rusty hand axe
and we'll give it some weak damage like
one
or two to two to four sure
i believe here we also need to specify
now the two-handed default ball balls so
that's fine okay now we just need a way
to
say what's actually in the uh what the
items are
so of course we're going to do this in
some graphical interface eventually but
for now let's just do a for loop
and go through each item however the
thing is
it's going to be messy because we're
going to have to call get data and then
on this data we're going to have to see
what it is and cast it and do all kinds
of stuff so we're going to put in a few
little tricks here
for now of some overloaded operators
that just help us with the sea out
manager so we're going to just include
iostream for testing
and we'll eventually remove it and
essentially what we want to do here i'm
just going to copy this over but i'll
explain it is we want to make
a friend operator
output stream
and i wrote this live on stream at some
point i think so i explained it at that
point but i need to explain it again i'm
sure
basically all this does is if you use c
out and pipe it this
it already knows about the stream
because of the operator but you need to
pass it an item and when you pass an
item it checks if it's armor if it's
armor it spits out this stuff here
if it ends up being a weapon it spits
out this stuff it ends up being potions
puts out this stuff so it's basically a
way to
uh help out and in any case yeah we
return all the stuff we're speeding out
so it's just going to give us some
information about it as you can see here
so this way in our main here
we can just we can just iterate through
that backpack
but we don't have a way to get to the
backpack because if we look at player
character backpack is private
so we're just going to work with a copy
right now so somewhere near where we
have getabilitylist to get buff list
let's also make a vector
of
this such a skit item list and these are
these these are not efficient they're
making copies they're pretty ugly
but uh
it's fine for now it's pretty small case
until the game gets big anyway and all
we're gonna do here is return backpack
uh maybe this should actually be like
get
backpack list or something i spill
backpack wrong
yeah i did
all right so it returns the backpack and
this is going to be a copy return if we
want to be like super safe we could make
these const just to make sure no one
messes with them
and in reality all of these gets should
be const so let's just go ahead and
clean that up real quick while we're at
it
do some serious const pasting
const pacing it almost sounds like
something else
it is generally good practice to make
all this stuff const uh that are just
getters
because you don't it basically disallows
modifying anything
that you're returning which can matter
and it's also going to help you keep
your code clean because it's going to
make sure that anything you're returning
is not being modified
so uh okay
we have a few ambiguous things here like
this equipped armor we now need it to be
get data
because as we changed it a bit ago
yeah i know it uh this has been we need
to update this code because of how we
updated how these equipped armors are
basically we need to be able to tell
that it's armor and we already know that
it is uh we just need to
basically
check if it's null or not because these
slots can be null
so that's something that's going to
change for printing out our character
class i'll go ahead and do that real
quick
all right well to redo these we have to
do some ugly
casting uh
well we know it's armor
so this should not fail the cast
but and without it being tested it could
however we have this other problem where
it says it's inaccessible or the data is
and we can of course
call get data otherwise it's going to
give us some errors with const and say
it can't cast const away so we need
actually to have access to data and to
do that i guess we're just going to have
to apply the quick hack of
making it a friend again which i didn't
really want to do but we're going to put
it back in here for now
otherwise we're going to be rewriting a
lot of functions but in reality we do
want to do this in a smarter way in the
long run
so we might do that down the long line
but for now i just want to get it
working so
we'll get that cast going and then just
get the armor from it and this shouldn't
even try to do this if there's nothing
equipped so this should be okay to do
every time
and we're essentially going to do the
same thing for all these other little
red
underscores
as we just got to do this cast so i'm
just going to copy this right here and
we'll straighten it out on all these
okay there it is on the get strength
from weapons we also want to get
strength from armor so it's going to
hey this is just in case they have
magical stuff we i think we did this a
long time ago in one of the episodes but
this should be strength here
okay because yeah this is in the get
strength uh yeah we just want to total
up this strength we might be getting
from magical armor and magical weapons
and put it all together
uh pretty standard stuff there but we're
just gonna have to write all these like
this for now
and while it is a bit tedious we should
be able to knock it out pretty quickly
with some copy pasta action
i'm literally just going down the line
doing this cast changing it to the stat
it's supposed to be
and then we'll do the same thing for
strength here in a second
so basically on all these get
total whatever it is after equipped
armor
into this armor cast making sure it's
getting the right thing
looks like we got all those and we just
need to do the same thing for weapons so
i'm going to go up to just get total
strength let's start here and we already
did this one
let's get the intellect from weapons
so this brings up a good point of
something i can say while we're stepping
through this because this is kind of
mindless code here just make sure we hit
it all correctly a lot of the points of
the things you design and design in an
intelligent way is basically so that
when you refactor or add something later
it doesn't become a huge pain
it's nice to be able to design in a way
where you can change it in one area and
it will dynamically change all your code
without you having to do this sort of
stuff so
often a sign that it needs refactored to
be done in a smarter way is if one thing
changes you got to go through and change
every function that's usually a sign
that
you mess something up in your design
but
i have sort of mixed opinions about that
because that's not necessarily true
like sometimes you just need to get it
done
and trying to refactor it will take way
longer than fixing it so you can use
your own discretion but if it becomes
way tedious then for sure you're
probably wanting to refactor all right
we got one more red mark over here let's
see if we can find it what is this i'll
just a final equipped weapon here
okay
grab that code put the cast in there
there we go
i don't see any more red dots over here
i think we're good i think we've got
everything we need
so we're going to go back to our main
and just finish this loop let's get the
inventory list
auto inventory equals p1.get
backpack list
and we'll just hit it right through this
with some auto
and we can use the beauty of that
overloaded function to just do that and
it should spit out all the details about
it and let's just separate it with
commas
and maybe we'll say before we actually
do this
inventory
so it'll say inventory and then it'll
just list everything all right so
i think we're good here
what we should see is we should see that
the character has the long sword and
leather armor equipped and we should see
that they have a heel potion
full plate and a rusty hand axe in their
inventory oh let's actually put this
into their inventory with uh move to
backpack here
rusty
and you know what we could even call
this
create weapon
right inside like here
that would actually work
so we don't necessarily need to store it
we're just going to move to the backpack
right away we can just create it
like so so just another little trick
there
all right but i do want to try to try
using things out of the backpack and see
if that works because we're making three
of them when we actually see the
backpack list we should see a quantity
three because one got used so let's just
make sure that works all right here we
go would you believe that we got no
compiler errors and i did not cut this
we just did all that with no compiler
errors amazing
okay so let's analyze a little bit this
didn't build highlight we have compiled
errors
we have some build tools platform
toolset problem what am i using here
i'm using visual studio 2019 oops
this is all targeted to 2022 so
let's just exit here
and i'm going to reopen this solution
open with visual studio 2022
and hey we got our old theme back
so i guess ignore my rant about the
whole theme thing earlier because it's
kind of not relevant actually we just i
accidentally opened it with the wrong
version all right let's see if we build
this so that wasn't a build error
technically but we do have some here
let's have a look
uh we accidentally typed an f in here
it's not supposed to be there backpack
is now part of the character
so it's going to correct that and that
seems to be it
very small things
and we built successfully let's go ahead
and hit play
oh it went
looks like we got an exception thrown
where our pc class
something about
this.pc class was null pointer and
that's at this get equipped armor at
so yeah that's the thing we want to
return we want to make sure this isn't
null
a valid point
so let's just have a look at where we're
calling this get equipped armor at
it's calling right here in this cast
uh just where we're checking our armor
list
so what's going on here
it's getting the data it's returning a
dynamic cast this should fail
okay so i guess here we want to uh
we just want to do a check
if equipped
armor at i if not equipped
we want to return a null pointer or we
could return it if it's null
let's just see what that does all right
let's give this a run so we might have
had a little logic errors here
undeclared equipped so i spelled a quick
wrong let's try that again
and now we get it at the weapon okay
because the way we change these equipped
armor and weapons yeah it makes sense
that
now we need to also make sure this isn't
null ahead of time
because as long as this isn't null these
uh equipped armors then the data there
should be something in the data but yeah
that's it
all right we're getting some strange
things happening on the inventory here
we can analyze this here in a second
but let's just make sure everything else
looks okay let's look at the level 2
warrior right here
it shows that
well most of the stuff looks fine armor
he's got the leather armor on it's got a
long sword equipped uh health potion
seems to be working fine inventory is
holding three items except that it's
showing the pointers so what does that
mean if it's showing the pointers well
it's not calling the overload that's one
thing for sure
so we're looking down here
this is not calling the overload
because these inventory pieces are
pointers we need to de-reference them to
get the actual item because it's the
actual item that oh
doesn't work yeah we're basically
getting a pointer
that lives in the vector with that so to
get the actual item we need to
de-reference it and then it should say
the stuff yep it does okay cool uh let's
do it this way
oh seems to be doing okay okay so we
know the rest of the stuff works fine
let's take a look at this inventory to
make sure it looks good shiny plate
armor that's correct
heel potion two left very good and
there's that rusty hand axe that we put
into our inventory that all looks pretty
good let's try one last thing
what happens if we just use all these
potions
use two more potions
and the tricky thing about this is we
need to hold this reference to it to be
able to use it so we'll probably sort
that out later to be able to use things
from the backpack but we sort of need an
interface to work with that which we
have not built and then let's just do
this inventory again
after using potions because what we're
expecting to happen here is after it
uses the last potion it should get it
should hit this quantity equal zero
mark the item for deletion and call
cleanup backpack so we just want to make
sure cleanup backpack actually removes
the items marked for deletion and we
don't get any dereference errors okay
something failed there what failed
oh it's just a redefinition uh
yeah
so we probably want to isolate these
we're not declaring anything that we
want to keep permanently in scope here
so let's just put these each in their
own scope like that and that should
solve that problem as a quick hack there
so let's look at the bottom
and just see that this looks correct
it's a that's a lot of info oh we need
to let's let's break a new line here all
right so just uh in between these
let's just put a new line in here
somewhere
that way we can tell what's going on
and it looks like we do have a bit of a
problem it is
oh no this isn't a problem this is
actually fine we called use potion but
after using potions the thing is it
didn't reduce their quantity but there's
a reason for that and it's because when
we call use on the potion
their health is full and it doesn't have
a buff so it doesn't actually use the
potion since they're full health so
that's actually working as intended but
we can we can fix that let's just make
them take like 20 damage so they need
some heels all right and then let's do
it and it should use up the potions
uh very good inventory after using
potions potions are gone as intended as
you can see they their health is
further down but after using these two
if we spit out the health again it
should say 16. we could check that if we
really wanted to let's just do it for
the heck of it there we go put it right
there
after using two potions
all right so this main code is getting a
bit messy there we go all right but this
is all this whole item setup is actually
working quite good i know this episode
is probably really long i'm going to cut
it as much as possible
but we got some important work done here
and uh yeah super awesome
i hope you learned a lot if you're
managing to follow along with this um
you're probably going to learn a lot
a lot of new understanding about how
pointers and memory works and if it's
still kind of puzzling you just keep
practicing with it and just do your best
to wrap your head around these things it
does just take time to fully understand
this but
maybe some of the times when i'm
explaining it just like listen to that a
few times and until it kind of clicks
but
yeah it's really important stuff to get
right and chances are we're messing up a
few things here but overall in our
initial testing seems to be working fine
and next episode i'm going to intend on
turning this more into a library and
building some tests because right now
we're running into the well it's not
technically an issue but it's odd this
main is essentially just a big test
runner it just does a bunch of things
and we're just checking the output to
see if it looks as we intend but we can
do better because we can actually build
tests and then we can do some test
driven development where
we know what we want it to do so we
write the test and then we write the
code and see if it passes the test
it's going to be a great case for that
because this main is getting real messy
and
it's
turning it's turning into chaos and then
basically what we can do from there is
we can actually design a real game
and use all the stuff and when we build
new stuff we can you know run the test
to make sure the new stuff we're
building is working correct etc etc but
essentially
this code all this code is going to be
put into tests except instead of like
looking at c out and seeing what is in
there we'll just do comparisons we'll
just like
basically say okay after we do this
action what are we expecting make some
asserts and see if it passes or fails so
that way we don't need to analyze our
see outs and
all this console code but that gets real
tedious on the eyes it's better to just
have a nice list of potion use pass fail
inventory delete pass fail you know down
the line
and those will that'll be a million
times better
all right don't forget to like and
subscribe this has been episode
12. i'm kind of losing track i'm still
intending to go to episode 20 and
i'm starting to kind of debate where i
want to take these final episodes so
leave a comment
and if you really want to influence
um i'm going to listen to the patrons
and members of the channel so if you
sign up over there at any of the tiers
i'm going to be asking over there and
highly considering but also i'll look at
the consensus of general youtube stuff
but i take uh most youtube comments with
a very large grain of salt even if i can
read them at all at this point i will
say that like
some days enough comments come in that i
literally can't read them all it would
just be a almost a full-time job on its
own just to respond so um
i'm probably going to be getting a
little more picky as time goes on i just
have so many videos at this point that
people comment on old ones all the time
and stuff and the queue just fills up
very quickly
and if i'm not answering them right away
it stacks up huge and there's no way i'm
going to get to them all so
yeah definitely going to be prioritizing
you know paid supporters and stuff like
that so just an fyi i think it's the way
it's got to be in the future all right
appreciate you guys and hope you're
learning a lot stay tuned for the next
upcoming episode
and uh peace out happy coding
[Music]
you